hey wait wait gotta go
what today we're gonna play some of the
scariest game on the market dot X again
they're really scary
alright so we're playing happy mouse
starting see oh my god so spooks I can
dig this music like I'm a VIP oh look at
even the clouds are smiling today's my
day oh oh but it's going on ah this make
you make you don't kill yourself
what the [ __ ] making what when I tell
you about melting your face Mickey you
melt the cheese not your face oh my god
Mickey the [ __ ] is happening make it
don't look at me like that oh shut up
shut your damn mouth is it over up yep
it's over next game got Bendix see
well [ __ ] me wet him some of these are
[ __ ] creepy all right are you too
spooked out yet let's do something a
little bit more lighthearted whatever
that means
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm a whiskers
great oh-oh-oh
what the what the mir Mattias is that a
penis that's a paint penis read is for
me and tell me how much did you feel XD
meat suits kiss boots Kenya writes
Buzzard ah your van your Z by nasal
analgesia main shut up a sonic are you
doing let's why your dog is sanic I love
this song by the way it's one of the
classics my headphones oh no it sanic be
like no sanic now what are you doing
alright [ __ ] me sanic way you Judas
and I'm a whiskas you beastie oh oh we
only got Eggman left fingers and wood
appears that that's fingers
oh no don't [ __ ] me big
and it's finished press ENTER to whiskas
okay Oh
[Music]
now although I'm killing them
sorry kitties I'm so sorry
thanks for playing press escape to live
I so beautiful let's play alone alone
dad XE which is very famous this may be
my last horror game I know a lot of you
guys just like these ACC games
that's why I'll stop making doubt but
remember this game was made by Nova
where I'll never forget I'll never
forget that means it's good or at least
better than most XE games out there
press space to interact hey hey what say
ah rata with my top down I just skip my
hold on where's my pick at you [ __ ]
well I don't see why anyone could
dislike his games they're so good
how you should have left damnit Pikachu
damn it's a pit Pik pika pika [ __ ] pick
up don't make me don't make me slap it
stop it's really [ __ ] creepy okay
sorry I forgot to feed you sorry don't
give me that look alright
okay now you're just getting annoying
pika what just knock it off I won't let
you do this to me the game has just
begun not really
just [ __ ] ended cars Carlton to say
you
damnit cotton this is no game what is
that noise coming from
I got damn it cotton stop bigtire oven
next game oh I didn't xee escape you
scared you up of course of course pits
of cars yes oh [ __ ]
ah [ __ ]
how do i oh oh decide I can show you I'm
rendering fabulous I don't know the
lyrics to this song but I met hey it's a
food it works like this whoo and that's
some freaky [ __ ] I don't know why I'm
digging this
oh no it's Aladdin Aladdin what are you
doing yeah he was no more monkeying
around Apple wanna try again no I'm good
okay and dancing I'm dancin I'm dancing
I'm dancing what is going on oh god damn
it Aladdin stop damn it a lot about and
faculty dude I'm chilling in the corner
maybe you can touch me here don't stab
my rest in peace headphone users no more
wishes for you genie would you all right
just pimpin regular day as a pimp look
at him he's so total pimp is reigning
Aladdin everyone is dead and soon you
will be too ready for round two
do you Bruce have a good idea what's
going on because I am no [ __ ] clue
I specifically order around - damn it
sorry - question everything in what I'm
doing with my life at the moment oh my
god I'm warning for ages girl [ __ ]
please right I know what I'm doing
oh god there's every game I had play I
have to be in pain oh my god I was [ __ ]
hey moustache man oh my god
what happened I can't possibly who could
have done Zhu gab all this [ __ ] maybe
maybe the doctor can help yeah just
[ __ ] tape them together hey I'm alive
alright well I better go to this puddle
and a giant potato a square potato my
favorite kind
a dead feet
hello dead fetus well I'd we had this
talk fetus oh this this my I'm alright
Oh giant black penis hey you dropped
your pen spin [ __ ] I don't know hey yo
I'm deaf you [ __ ]
absolutely hate how people just randomly
create crappy XE games they do nothing
except leave more [ __ ] for me to clean
up just like how many times their to
bring that bastard blue hedgehog to
reality so do you think you could bring
me back alive just like you did with the
hedgehog what do you think I have a
[ __ ] genie all right fine all right
thank you look at that happy face so
[ __ ] happy really
the doctor had a gun ready are you
[ __ ] kidding me god damn it
ha ha the end yes
this has to be my favorite EXA game at
all oh my god I hear little crying MLG
kids
I collected Shrek's penis I must cleanse
it from this land this evil cannot exist
in this world
I hear the demon cry now it's just a 12
year old kid playing xbox it's kind of
turning me on I don't it's [ __ ] weird
I don't stop it down there I will be
accepted into faze clan but first I must
cleanse this screen Shrek penis [ __ ]
Shrek what are you doing to my hair
let's finish this off by smiled that
EXCI it looks like a virus I'm scared I
have to pee really bad - okay really bad
Oh
[Music]
ow oh I'm so [ __ ] happy hey you know
you're happy when you can't just [ __ ]
walk like a normal person Jesus Christ
hey how you doing rainbow [ __ ] go back
thank you miss one what god damn it
what's with her eyes smile sorry hey now
I'm smiling a [ __ ] oh what the hell oh
my god just smile